en lugar de conchas marinas estas olas
se están tragando la ropa vieja y
arrojándola a lo largo de la playa por
cientos de metros estos miles de
artículos que antes usaban los
occidentales terminan su vida aquí
contaminando la costa de ghana
cómo
también es un problema en accra la
capital esta es una pequeña montaña de
telas que ha surgido y crecido en los
últimos 15 años
con 20 metros de altura es una
monstruosidad que sigue creciendo
los gatos
entre los desechos se encuentran
conocidas marcas europeas y americanas
ese es central
es esa la diestra
de su área
todo esto que estamos viendo lo estamos
quemando todo ese tiempo lo estamos
quemando pero aún así el problema es
demasiado para nosotros nos está
causando enfermedades fiebre el dolor de
cabeza y muchas otras cosas el humo de
estos incendios es tóxico aunque aquí no
se han realizado estudios para averiguar
el grado de toxicidad
cada día los barcos traen otras 160
toneladas de ropa vieja al país ropa que
fue donada a organizaciones benéficas en
europa o en eeuu pero que no se quiere
en los países desarrollados aquí es
donde las empresas internacionales de
reciclaje envían la ropa
en el mercado canta monto se revenden
por el equivalente a unos céntimos por
kilo
compramos ropa de segunda mano y la
vendemos por eso venimos aquí para
comprar esto viene de londres dubai
canadá
vengan a toda una economía ha florecido
en torno a la ropa de segunda mano
en la cima del sistema están los
mayoristas
sobre el
vestido para niños bebés talla m
esta es la ropa interior para hombres
estoy hablando de un gran negocio no
venda tienda es muy grande y normalmente
descargamos dos o tres cargamentos al
mes
a continuación la ropa es clasificada y
vendida por comerciantes más pequeños y
cada uno tiene su especialidad como los
zapatos o la lencería pero muy pocas
prendas están realmente en condiciones
de ser vendidas y usadas esta vendedor
del mercado acaba de comprar 55
kilogramos de ropa
pero es decepcionante
basura basura es sólo basura nadie
compra así que algo como esto no podemos
vender es muy malo nadie lo compra y al
final del día uno sale perdiendo
el resultado montañas de ropa invendible
van a parar al vertedero
cada día se botan más de 70 toneladas en
este mercado un desastre ecológico
una ong está tratando de comprender
mejor todo el impacto medioambiental de
esta contaminación textil
intensidad
se puede ver que la ropa está
incorporada al entorno así que está
creando una catástrofe medioambiental en
la que sacar este material de la arena
está siendo dominante tratar a muchos
años más en degradarse y en ese proceso
liberará microfibras y toxinas nocivas
para el medio ambiente
la ex estilista neoyorquina convertida
en activista ecológica culpa a las
marcas de moda occidentales
lo que la gente tiene que entender es
que lo que están viendo aquí en la línea
de costa base visible un problema que
está en su propio armario por ello
debemos asumir una mayor responsabilidad
y cambiar nuestros hábitos de consumo
y
los artículos de moda tienen una vida
cada vez más corta cada año se tira el
equivalente a 50 mil millones de
camisetas una de cada ocho acabará en
una playa africana como esta o en un
vertedero
[Música]